hey y'all we've got an exciting
announcement spectrum is now a game
that's right we've heard your cry we've
just launched our kickstarter so please
go and support it now
we hope you love it
[Music]
i love bye man i'm very attracted to
trans men but that would still make me
gay though because they're always yeah
that just means you're super gay
[Music]
this reminds me of the marker game like
when like trivia was like the marker in
like seventh grade who is most likely to
pull a prank
really
you did
you ripped up a donut but that's only
because he pulled so many pranks on me
that i was getting him back oh
throughout the seasons i think it's you
i'm like the least maybe with him and i
have a better relationship and he likes
to pull you ripped off my toenail not to
be a narcissist but what about me
what have you ever pulled apart
constantly like whenever we're really
tired and it's been like a 12 hour day
i'm like oh i just found out we have
another six hours and then you guys all
get into like a big hufflepuff you
literally like never made that joke who
is more likely to win america's next top
model oh three two
sorry also me
thank you for your participation who's
more likely
to tell it like it is
oh three two one
who is more likely to send you a
thoughtful message or gift just because
that's cute jackie thanks baby you're
like the only one who does nice stuff
cromwell actually just randomly sends me
messages anthony will often send gifts
very sweet and he took you on that
vacation and he took notification to
mexico who is more likely to get stopped
on the street
um well it's really tim i'm going to say
anthony only because his reaction's the
funniest
um he pretends like he doesn't see you i
get overwhelmed pretend pretend to see
him
[Music]
i'm out goodbye thank you this was so
much fun
he used to get really nervous
i get severe social anxiety and i would
just get really overwhelmed and i get
like severe palpitations and i sweat
like crazy
being on queer eye was my dream three
two one go
once i heard about that audition honey
well i was ready i almost didn't show up
to the auditions because i had a trip
plan to spain and i was like there's no
way i'm going to get this i'm just going
to go to spain i've still never seen the
american uh i've never seen the
americans
really yeah i still remember exactly
where i was i was at three gold street
bobby what were your thoughts when you
watched um queer eye for the first time
i felt seen
you know especially seeing somebody like
tom who was in the industry that i
wanted to be in i i felt like all those
people my whole life that told me i
wouldn't amount to anything that i would
never find love that i would never be in
a normal relationship i would never live
a normal life
the five of them proved
that you could
i felt a deep i have to say it i felt a
deep tingling in my loins for cayenne oh
god yes yeah he really oh yeah i had a
huge crush on kyle oh my god
i worry that the people we help will
fall back into their old lifestyles
three two one go
i disagree because even if they go back
to their own lifestyles i like to think
that they had a nice little experience
and a moment in time they can go back to
whenever they're ready and they have
that willingness listen if you've chosen
to disregard everything we've said more
fool you i kind of agree that i worry
about it sometimes i think from my
category it's harder because they're not
just going to throw out everything i
gave them i don't know
well sometimes sometimes they have
okay this section is called hot takes
and we had our audience submit props
that they want to ask you guys the back
of this dress is really pretty so i
better sit like this for this one
i've had a crush on another fab five
member three two one go
i mean yeah
rude that's not true anthony get over
there
get over there right now i don't believe
you over there you were in love with me
for two seasons come on when i first met
kramer he knows this
i really was like oh my god like just
split me in half that's how i felt i
didn't think that but i just thought
he'd be nice to make out with i think we
all equally found each other very
attractive in the beginning but then we
all became like brothers and friends and
it that never happened but of course in
the beginning i think yeah i was
attracted to everybody i genuinely love
all of you but i've never i know what a
crush is like and it doesn't equate to
that i strongly disagree with him
that's what i strongly disagree with i
must take this strongly disagree cone
and put it up where the sun doesn't
shine because it's not true i have the
hardest job on the show three
two
one go
we'll just all go over here
wow i'm so shocked
absolutely absolutely this is this is
absolutely this is it this is what good
teamwork looks like yes
and then there's youtube
even though bobby has to like build an
entire house and everything
i feel like doing hair is really hard
and sometimes people are really upset
about it and sometimes i have to like
do haircuts on people who have no hair
and that's really hard i think i have
the most time time-consuming
job on our show i wouldn't say i
wouldn't say it's the hardest i'm just
kidding because there's been episodes
where tans had the hardest where
anthony's had the hardest one jonathan
we've all our jobs have all been hard in
different ways
yeah no he's definitely some that have
been hard to crack would we agree with
that i was at the salon 12 hours once
girl it takes me weeks to do episodes
weeks i would argue that a bolognese can
take three to four hours
[Laughter]
there were heroes who were tough to work
with three two one go
you idiot
yeah there's been a lot of them that are
hard i mean our show is an emotional
show there's a lot of times people don't
want to really go through the process
and it's hard sometimes to i know tan's
definitely struggled with that
willingness is not binary it's not black
and white it's not yes or no it comes in
all the different shapes and forms and
we love all our heroes equally can some
of them be a pain in the ass at times
yeah but do we give up no
pronouns should be on all name tags
three
two one go
tricky one
i have a question before i make a
decision what if
the person hasn't figured out their
pronouns yet and they're uncomfortable
and it's not something that they feel
comfortable assigning themselves to you
know the quickest you know the quickest
way to make those people comfortable
make it mandatory for everybody no but
if somebody's on their journey and it
takes yeah what if somebody hasn't if it
wasn't
if it was the norm for everyone to just
have it i feel like that i feel actually
i'm gonna
i feel like
making someone label themselves is
is what society's already trying to do
like you are you a man are you a woman
and you need to be i feel like making
you making somebody label themselves
before they're ready
is
i'm so torn on this one because i get i
can i can honestly stand at either end
of this and i feel strongly about both i
think that we need to afford people time
to really figure out who they are who
they want to be how they represent
themselves to the world the thought
of having to
um identify with a pronoun being such a
terrifying thing goes to show how much
we should dismantle the binary in the
first place because like that's part of
why i identify with he she they because
i don't feel that i've ever fit within
the binary at all so that's why i feel
really fluid to like flip between all of
them i'm personally really tired of
being misgendered and i think other
people that live outside of the gender
binary are sick of it so it's like if
you just had it out there it's like it
just makes it for easier for people to
like navigate something if they said
look there are no more
uh he
sheet there's only they i could
subscribe to that but i think if they
are forced to figure out a label then i
think that i think we're forcing people
to do something that they may not feel
comfortable just like i feel like it's
forcing somebody to have a very public
journey before they may be ready for it
and part of why i'm torn maybe i might
have like an internal confusion that's
going on right now with sexual hold on
one sec with sexuality and gender
because for me
sexuality like if i came out as gay and
i felt like i couldn't take it back but
maybe to your point it's not it's
different with gender i just can't
relate to it
gender
isn't important
three
two
one go wait
what
maybe i misunderstood that
because to me like what i think of is
gender important no it's not like
not in a way that it's not important
thing to think about for someone's
journey with gender is important but
like someone's definition of
gender isn't necessarily for some people
gender is incredibly important to them
and and
and that helps dictate who they are and
who they get to be and how they get to
feel most comfortable i think there's
been too much emphasis put on gender
especially by
commercialism of blue is for boys pink
is for girls and this is what defines
gender i think there's been too much
defining gender and i think the gender
should be fluid in whatever you feel
inside which is why to me i don't feel
as important but because for some people
it is important we have to respect that
and therefore it is important as a as as
a globe of humans
does that make sense yes i strongly
believe that it's very important because
of all the violence against women in the
violence against trans the violence it's
like so for me i feel like it's very
important because until we can dismantle
this oppressive murderous yes gender
binary that we are living with yeah i
feel like i
but bobby's idea is the goal yes yeah to
me i think of it as a goal that no it's
not important that's what you're saying
i understand the intention and i love
your intention i think it's great
i had a hard time accepting my sexuality
did you say had yes
three two one go
i
i'm from a very conservative community
as you all know and so i had time
reconciling how it was going to play out
in my future and so i always knew i was
gay i just didn't know if it was
something i was ever going to be able to
action without being
possibly
killed uh and so uh so yeah it was it
was hard it was a hard time reconciling
it but i always knew i was gay
internally i had no i feel like i knew
who i was and i felt like i knew what my
truth was i felt like the outside world
had like a
bigger
problem with it i struggled with it i
think a little like post-puberty when i
realized that i was attracted to boys
and girls honestly though even just
before queer i had a lot of people in my
life who just assumed that i was
straight landing that job and having my
life change and all of the jobs and
everything gave me this like confidence
that i didn't have before
queer representation in media has become
way better
three
two
one
go
the fact that i'm allowed on tv and i
don't mean allowed is in somebody gave
me permission but the fact that there's
somebody like me on tv blows my mind i
never thought in my lifetime a muslim
queer brown person would be on tv with
perfect hair with gorgeous hair yeah
when i was little the only person that
was out was ellen and obviously that
didn't end well for her then um and then
will and grace that wasn't even when i
was little that was still like early 20s
and i still think there's a lot of
broadcast shows that there is zero
representation in and there won't be
because that demographic won't be okay
with it it still makes headlines
whenever there's like a queer story
that's at the forefront of the leading
people whether it's people of color
anybody queer it still makes like a big
splash and it's like treated as it's
like a big deal so it's not normalized
yet there are still movies being banned
in middle eastern countries and even
just right here we have like so many you
know state legislatures that are trying
to ban books because they're silly silly
silly
sillies we are truly making a difference
in the world
three
two
one go
getting picked up from the my house on
the way to the airport yesterday morning
a
70 year old white man driver pulls up
and i get in the car and he looks at me
and he goes
i just have to say
your show has changed my family's life
my daughter's 27 and she is
transitioning
and we couldn't relate we couldn't
understand and we watched your show and
it allow it allows us to be able to
understand our daughter and what she is
going through and you guys have helped
my family heal and be there for our
daughter when there's no way we could
have before
moments like that really
make me proud of what we do
um and and make anything that you know
hot days this and that
yeah
make it all worth it because the the
reason that i stopped on somewhat is i
was like oh but there's always more
there we could always be doing more we
could always be making more progress but
i
i feel like what we're all doing what
we're all bringing i do feel like we are
changing the perceptions and i do feel
like we're making um a difference and i
feel really strongly about that out of
all the human interactions that we've
had and it's like yes i get very
overwhelmed when people stop me but like
it never gets old when you see like
multiple generations of families
stop you at an airport and be like this
is a show that we can watch as a family
i never thought i was gonna be part of
that narrative
i'm still shocked by it i know it may
seem arrogant to suggest that the work
that we're doing impacts the world and
makes a difference however having kids
from pakistan message to say i never
believed there was a future for me i
thought maybe that by the time i hit my
20s which is when we're meant to get
married i'd have to kill myself to know
that you are out there you've got a
partner you've now got a child you've
lived a life that you
that was normal for you and your country
is in a place that i
i dream our country will be that kind of
inspiration i it's priceless i don't
think that any of us can really quantify
what impact we make on the kids in
villages in pakistan who have never ever
ever believed that they have a life past
20. that blows my mind that's changing
the world
[Music]
thank you thank you thanks everyone
you